Với kinh nghiệm về dạng của một đại biểu của khối 2 khoá lì tiếp khoá mùi ba và mùi búng, ông trình gọt phương,
huy vình bán chấp hành bầu tình tây nền, bí thử đạng huy phương gòi dầu, chú tịch khối động
dân chân phương gòi dầu, tiếp tục được tính giềm, giới thiệu ứng cử đại biểu của khối khoá mùi sấu.
Sự kết hợp giữa trị thức chuyên mô của một tiếng sĩ quy hoặc và bán lĩnh推 ruyện
quà mùi năm trên nghỉ trường duyên hồng với hơn 8 giềm kì là tình huy vình,
hai lần làm vĩ thử huy vui tương vi và gọi dầu.
Mà lần làm giảm đốc các sở sẽ dừng sở kết hợp và đồ thư sở tại chính,
chính là nên tảng đế ông thực hiện chứ tình thành động để tâm huy của mình.
Công hai nhiệm kì của khối khoá mùi ba và mùi búng, ông trình gọt phương,
đã để lại nhiều giấu ứng đậm nét với phai gò lạc huy vình huy vình của bạn qua học công nghệ và mùi trường của khối.
Ông được cứ trị đánh giá cao mời nhìn phát biểu sách sảo thẳng thẳng và có tính phản biểu cao,
trong các viên thảo luận về xe dừng pháp luật,
nặc biệt là các dùi an lực xe dừng lực huy hoặc và lực bất đài,
lực kính chúc, lực băng hành quanh quy phạm pháp luật.
Không chỉ để lại giấu ứng tại gây dừng,
mà còn là tính nói sắc sảo trên truyền thông.
Sường tháng khán khi được kính nghỉ tử trì thành tâm diễm báo kiế của ông,
đã tạo áp lực tích trực, thuốc lấy các bộ ngàn dài huy tích điểm khóa càng,
buổi đáp điểm tinh và khi bỏ lấn từ nhân dân.
Cinh nghiệm từ việc thăm gia giám sắc tử cao các cùng trên tồng điểm khúc gia
và các chính sách phát triển kinh tính xa hồi,
đã tiếp ông có cá gình báo quát thật tiền,
để báo về quyền lời chính đáng của nhân dân,
những bài học huy hoống về kính năng lắm nghe,
tống hợp và chuyển tảng thời thử của sống vào các quyết sách của khồi,
chính là hành trang qua trong nhất mà ông mang theo trong lần ứng tử này.
Khi thường những thành tử từ cá gình kỳ trước,
trong truy trình thành động khoám xe sống,
ông trên ngọt phương, khánh định các trong tâm.
Thế nhất, việc tấu trong thành vượt tấu quốc của nhân dân,
của hảy hứng phát, nghiêm trình chấp hành được gấu của đảng chính sách phạt lịch của nhân dân.
Tường xin dự mối, nhưng hảy mặt thiết hồi cứ truy,
lắm nghe và tiếp tục đầy đấu phản ảnh Trung thật,
kẹp thời sống tư, mẹ nhận chính sáng của nhân dân của khồi,
và các cơ quan và thông quên.
Tử hài sẽ thêm một cật nghiêm tốt,
chật vẻ mùa hế hoạ tương trình hoặc đầm của khồi,
không ngừng ngắn cao khoảng lệnh,
ngắn lực và tính thành,
không sử nhận dân của người dài biểu hố hồi.
Đủ đọng thích cật,
thăm ra sẽ dân hồi hoàn tỉnh hẹn thông quốc lệnh,
ngắn cao chực lưu vọng gần lập pháp và giám sách,
vứa phần bỏ đám quyền là ở pháp chính đáng của nhân dân.
Không có nhiều đánh của cứ truy, vứa hoặc khách cơ quan,
chứa bà,
quan tâm xâu sắc, lấy các chiếm đầy ăn xen sau khi khật kiến trên tế bình dẫn,
tục đẩy vào gịch ám,
ngắn cao chung nhập và giặc lưu vọng gần lực xong của người dân.
Mà ho giảm sử pháp kiến hà hòa,
dầu tăng trưởng tình tế và tính bỏ trong vòng xa hồi.
Đủ đọng,
bởi giật giảm đầy tính hư dân,
chứa sẽ cùng hập hủy và giá phương,
tập trung lần đầy vào tập kìa cắt người quyết của đạn,
ngắn cao chực lưu vọng gần đầy ăn,
pháp kiến trên tế hòa hồi,
vụ dựng quốc phần linh,
vụ phần ổng đầy vào pháp kiến dị vương.
Trăng gần tiếp xúc cửa trây theo dình,
vụ mối dân hà cho mình xin chặt trẻ hôn nhân dân.
Trẻ hồi đông đọc và giám sát
việc kia quyết các kinh ngày của bước trây.
Mỏ đám cao kìa kinh được xem sát,
sự lý nghiêm tốt,
lúng quyền hôn bất lực.
Mằng tất cả lòng nghi quyết và kinh nghiệm đã tất lý,
tôi nhuyền quyết tâm khoảng thần thuốc giềm bù của người đại biểu gương chân.
Đặt lại đi bình pháp ki vòng mặt đứa trị tính nhà,
đại gửi cầm.